welcome back to New rockstars I'm Winnie
van laningham and it's time to grab a
tuna sandwich no crust because fast X is
almost here and listen there are nine
movies in the Fast and Furious saga 10
if you can't Hobbs and Shaw which I
absolutely do it might not have had time
in your busy life to sit down and watch
25 hours of hot babes fast cars and
familial bonding but I have so today I'm
taking you a quarter mile at a time
through a quick and dirty recap of the
Fast and the Furious franchise to make
sure you're revved up for fast X The
Fast and the Furious made its debut in
2001 and introduces us to LAPD officer
Brian O'Connor a blonde haired blue-eyed
angel with a hatred of speed limits and
a hankering for tuna well no one likes a
tuna here yeah well I do the FBI sends
him undercover to investigate a high
string of Honda Civics seen robbing a
bunch of semi trucks for valuable
Electronics if you want to feel old yes
they were stealing Panasonic televisions
with vcr and DVD capabilities after
earning the respect of Vin Diesel's
Dominic Toretto in a street race Brian
successfully infiltrates the fastest
family to ever grace the Silver Screen
this crew that will one day be future
super spies is comprised of auto
mechanic and born leader Dominic Toretto
his sweet younger sister Mia his Rough
and Tumble ride or die Letty Ortiz the
egotistical Vince some guy named Leon
who you do not need to commit to memory
and Jesse a boy Genius who unfortunately
gets killed by a rival street racing
game while undercover Gathering Intel on
Dom's crew Brian falls in love with Mia
and the thrill of the race when he
learns that the semi-truck drivers are
armed with shotguns ready to defend
their Radio Shack shipment at all costs
Brian comes clean to Nia and convinces
her to help him save Dom and his crew
when Vince is shot by one of the drivers
Brian is forced to blow his cover when
he calls in emergency backup to save his
life Dom and Brian race one last time to
see who's a better driver and although
both of them narrowly miss getting
pancaked by a train Brian wins out of
respect Brian gives Dom his car keys
fulfilling the promise he made after
their first race to give him a 10 second
car and Dom escapes to Baja California
and Mexico Too Fast Too Furious fellows
Brian O'Connor's Journey after obviously
getting fired from law enforcement for
letting a career criminal use his car to
escape he and Ludacris's tej run illegal
street races out of Miami but when
they're caught Brian's former colleague
at the FBI presents him with a deal
he'll clear Brian's criminal record if
he goes undercover again to help them
bring down drug lord Carter Varone Brian
enlists his childhood bestie Roman
Pierce to help him in exchange for the
same deal with Johnny La agent Monica
Fuentes has been undercover with veroni
for a year and she helps them gain her
boss's Trust From the Inside although
she warns both customs and the FBI that
Varone will kill Roman and Brian once
he's successfully smuggled his money
away on a private jet the agents refused
to call off the mission instead of going
to the Airfield however varoni's men
along with Brian and Roman are
instructed to transport his duffel bags
of money to a marina surprise veroni
knew that Monica was an FBI agent the
whole time and he double-crossed her as
he attempts to flee on his private yacht
the fast boys launched their car onto
varoni's getaway boat squishing it and
saving Monica's life with their records
cleared Brian and Roman decided to take
the money that Romans stole from verone
and opened a garage in Miami together
like any real fast fan knows we're
moving on to Fast and Furious the fourth
installment of the franchise and the
next chronological sequence of the Saga
welcome back to Tokyo Drift when the
timeline's ready Dom and his crew are
still on the run from the law and now
have a few new additions Han an expert
Drifter Tego and Rico a freaking Frack
Duo and Kara the sister of cardi B's F9
character Lisa This Crew has a gig
hijacking fuel tankers in the Dominican
Republic but after a heist goes sour Han
tells Dom that the cops are on their
tails so the crew splits up Dom leaves
Letty behind in order to protect her and
a few months later he gets a call from
Mia informing him that the love of his
life was killed in a car accident
meanwhile Brian O'Connor is searching
for drug lord arturobraga while the FBI
secures a spot for Brian in a street
race to get in closer to the criminals
Dom rolls up ready to race his old
friend for a spot in braga's crew after
finding nitromethane at the scene of
letty's accident Dom also discovered
that Braga might have been behind her
death as well braga's associate giselia
Shar informs the drivers that the winner
will help Braga transport heroin across
the Mexican border through a series of
tunnels during their mission Dominic
learns that all of the drivers are
killed after making their drops and that
Letty was taken out after she discovered
what was happening and fought back turns
out that she was working undercover for
the FBI alongside Brian in order to
clear Dom's name hoping that he would
return to her once the threat of jail
time was eliminated when the cops kicked
Brian off the case he and Dom go Rogue
to finally fight and capture Braga who
is promptly arrested when they drag him
back to the USA although they managed to
bring Braga to Justice Dominic's name
still hasn't been cleared he's sentenced
to 25 years to life in prison but as the
bus drives him towards the slammer his
family shows up to rescue him in Fast
Five Dom Mia and Brian flee to Rio De
Janeiro where fins hooks them up with a
job stealing cars from a moving train
the car that Mia drives off in belongs
to drug lord Hernan Reyes and has a
computer chip detailing the locations of
his money stashes Dom and Brian are
captured by reyes's hitman's easy who
kills a bunch of DEA agents in the
process in response to these deaths the
US's Diplomatic Security Service sends
agents Lou Cobbs and Elena Neves to
bring the family to Justice believing
that they were responsible for these
deaths luckily the fast boys Escape
Reyes in the aftermath Dom suggests
splitting up for their safety but Mia
announces that she's pregnant with
Brian's child with a new mouth to feed
in all the financial details of reyes's
criminal Empire in their possession the
family agrees to do one last Heist the
crew assembles some of their greatest
allies Han Giselle Rico and Tego and tej
who went from a hyped man to a tech
Super Genius since we last saw him they
also form an alliance with Hobbes and
Elena under the guise of catching Reyes
Reyes has his money inside a vault
inside of a corrupt police station so
the family steals some cop cars attaches
them to the Vault and Yanks it straight
out of the building dragging it down the
street like a wrecking ball and this is
where fast X comes in just behind that
safe Dante Reyes hernan's son was
lurking this whole time but when Dom and
Brian wreaked havoc with the Vault Papa
Reyes was killed and Dante was flung
into the drink now he's out to destroy
the toretos and their extended family
for slaying his father to be fair to the
family though they also faced great loss
in this Heist poor Vince gets killed but
hey the family successfully pulled a
fast one on both Reyes and Hobbes so now
they're multi-millionaires plus Dom is
starting to move on from letty's Death
with defective agent Elena while Brian
and Dom have their classic end of the
movie race Hobbs receives a file on
Letty who is Alive and Well regarding
the hijacking of a military Convoy in
Berlin we made this video with the help
of geology and with their help you can
make your skin healthier than ever
geology is a 22-time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health Oprah daily hypebeast
birdie Esquire and GQ they're proud
products are built around just a handful
of powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
geology's co-wash and deodorant are
great and I use them all the time but
right now they're running a special
offer for a skin care sampler Pat and
geology skincare stuff is in a league of
its own geology's line of skin care
products can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging there's
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a very limited time
use code Rockstar's 100 to get 100 off
of your personalized 30 day skincare
sample set all you have to do is cover
the 495 for shipping on top of that new
rockstars fans get an exclusive bonus
offer of up to 50 off on an additional
skin hair and body product of your
choice when you add it to your trial
click the link in the description or go
to
geology.i.e Rockstar 100 to get started
we're now at fast 6. the franchise has
gone full spy Thriller Hobbs is
investigating the destruction of a
Russian military Convoy leading him to
Rogue British SAS major and special ops
Soldier Owen Shaw Hobbs convinces Dom to
Rally the team offering the family's
Freedom if they succeed in stopping Shaw
from using a technology called
Nightshade capable of shutting down all
the power across the globe to sweeten
the pot he also reveals that Letty is
alive when Dom catches up to her it's
clear by the shots she fires that she
doesn't remember him although she
survived her altercation with braga's
henchman Felix she has no memory of her
past life with dom Brian discovers that
Shaw helped Braga build his criminal
Empire and tej tracks Shaw's next attack
to a NATO base where he plans to attack
the military Convoy carrying the
computer chip he needs for Nightshade
one tank battle a mirror match and a
tough Bruiser lady Team Swap later
Shaw's men have kidnapped Mia and hopped
aboard an airplane the family tries to
stop it from taking off the best way
they know how by buying their cars to it
and driving real fast Brian rescues Mia
and Dom drives his Dodge Charger out of
the plane before it explodes but sadly
Giselle sacrifices her life to save Han
from the blast back in La Elena and Dom
break up and Letty moves back into Casa
del Toretto just in time for family
dinner but back in Tokyo where Han has
gone to mourn Giselle Owen Shaw's
younger brother Deckard kills Han in
retaliation for his siblings injuries
leaving Dom's cross necklace at the
scene of the murder alright now it's
time for Tokyo Drift which technically
takes place here right before deckard's
arrival at the very end of fast six does
it make sense no but this is the
timeline when high school student Sean
Boswell gets in trouble for illegal
street racing he's sent to live with his
dad in Tokyo to evade jail time he's
introduced to drift racing by his friend
Twinkie and Han ends up taking him under
his wing and teaching him how to Tokyo
Drift unfortunately Han is seemingly
killed in an explosion caused by an
accident with the Yakuza but now we know
that Deckard Shaw was behind his death
the whole time
in a post-credits scene Dom shows up to
Rayshawn informing him that he and Han
were family okay now we gotta Flash
Forward from 2006 to 2015 for furious 7.
back in Los Angeles Dom is still trying
to help Letty regain her memories and
Brian is struggling to adjust to Life as
a minivan Dad we see Deckard break into
Owen's hospital room where his brother
is still in a coma next he breaks into
the DSs field office in LA to get info
on the family he detonates a bomb that
injures Hobbes and sends a letter bomb
to the Toretto house where it explodes
Dominic learns that Han is dead and
travels to Tokyo where we just saw him
in the post credits of fast three after
mourning Han and Giselle at their
funerals a government special ops team
led by Mr Nobody promises the family
that their team will help them stop Shaw
if they retrieve a computer program
called God's eye which is capable of
tracking a specific individual using
anything on a digital Network he also
asks them to save God's eyes Creator
Ramsay from a terrorist named Moses
Sunday after air dropping their cars
from the sky they rescue Ramsay and head
to Dubai where Brian and Dom jumped
their cars between not two but three
high-rise buildings to pick up God's eye
the team tries to use God's eye to track
down Shaw but jakande's henchmen strike
taking it with them when Dom heads off
to fight Shaw alone Mia tells Brian that
she's pregnant again and he vows to do
whatever it takes to keep their family
safe Hobbs breaks out of the hospital to
help them like this that is
while Ramsay hacks into God's eye with
jakande in Hot Pursuit Damon Shaw face
off on the roof of a parking garage Dom
collapses the structure and tries to
crash his Dodge Charger into jacande's
helicopter although he fails he does
manage to toss a bag of grenades in
there which Hobbs shoots causing an
explosion Shaw is arrested in the
aftermath Dom is knocked unconscious but
Letty wakes him up by finally
remembering their wedding night at the
beach the family realizes that Brian is
finally happier with being a minivan dad
than he is being a car racing
International crime stopper and they
watch him play in the ocean with his
pregnant wife and son Brian and Dom
raced each other one last time while
it's been a long day without you my
friend plays in the background of their
friendship Montage R.I.P Paul Walker
gone from this world but alive somewhere
in a minivan in the FCU now let's get
into fate of the Furious A mysterious
woman named Cipher shows Dom some photos
that convince him to betray the family
and work for her cyber terrorism ring
instead Mr Nobody recruits Hobbs and
Shaw to track down Dom and Cipher and
reveals that Cipher was also Behind The
Nightshade device and God's eye Dom
steals God's eye for Cipher and she
tells him that she's kidnapped Elena and
the son he unwingly fathered with her
for collateral this convinces him to
steal a nuclear football to help Cipher
start nuclear war but he manages to
sneak away to contact Deckard and Owen's
mom Queenie Shaw he promises her son's
freedom in exchange for her help
rescuing his own son after Cipher kills
Elena to assert dominance Dom helps her
hack a nuclear submarine but as soon as
the Shah Brothers secure his kid he
turns on her and rejoins the family
although they manage to prevent nuclear
war Mr Nobody confirms that Cipher
survived after parachuting out of a
plane at the end Shaw has welcomed into
the family and Dom introduces the whole
crew to his son we decided to name Brian
in a fast Saga spin-off that's still all
about family Hobbs and Shaw team up to
save Shaw's sister Hattie and stop a
programmable super virus called
snowflake from spreading across the
globe and while I don't think that
there's going to be a ton of references
from this movie in fast acts we were
introduced to some interesting Concepts
that I think might come back the villain
Brixton lore has basically the same
Powers as any MCU Baddie including
superhuman strength durability speed a
bionic spine ocular implants and
bulletproof prosthetic arms based on the
constant ramp up of tech in this
franchise I wouldn't be surprised if we
saw another villain with tricked out
body modification in the future the most
important part of Hobbs and Shah however
is that Hobbs finally makes peace with
his brother and enjoys retirement in
Samoa and Deckard and Hattie break their
mom Queenie out of jail just in time for
fast nine the last time we saw the
toretos on the Silver Screen we learned
about Dominic Mia and their estranged
brother Jacob's tragic past in 1989 the
patriarch of the family Jack Toretto was
killed in an accident during one of his
races down at the track it turns out
that Daddy Toretto was deep in with the
sharks and asked Jacob to cut the wires
on his car to ensure he'd lose the race
in order to win some money not knowing
why his brother tampered with their
father's vehicle Dom exiled Jacob from
the family in present day two years
after their battle with Cipher Dom and
Letty are raising Little Brian Off the
Grid when Roman tejan Ramsay
unexpectedly arrive with a mission Mr
Nobody was able to find an arrest Cipher
but his plane was attacked by Rogue
agents who kidnapped her and blew up the
aircraft I never trust an off-screen
death which is why I'm so curious to see
what they do with brie Larson's
character is his daughter is she here to
avenge her dad's death was she part of
it or is Mr Nobody still alive and
hiding somewhere he said it himself he's
the master of making a fake out death
look real leaving Little Brian with the
O'Connors let he and Dom help the family
investigate and Dom discovers Jacob's
involvement the family learns that Han
was also linked to project Aries a
device capable of hacking into any
computer-controlled system they find Han
alive in Tokyo protecting a young girl
named Elle whose parents invented
project Aries Mom and Dad sealed the
dangerous device with their own DNA
making L the only key able to unlock it
when Jacob went rogue Mr Nobody helped
Han fake his death and go into hiding in
order to protect her Jacob and his men
steal project Aries and force L to
activate it and his associates begin to
upload it to a satellite in orbit so
that they can hack into every single
computer on the planet using a rocket
car built by Sean and Twinkie from Tokyo
Drift and their buddy Earl tejan Roman
launched into space and nearly
sacrificed their lives to destroy a
satellite luckily the folks at the
International Space Station are able to
give them a lift home because why not
that totally happens all the time Cypher
convinces Jacob's partner to double
cross him so Jacob flips back to team
Toretto once and for all although Cipher
escapes the only thing that matters is
family and Dom Jacob and Mia are finally
together again at last mirroring what
Brian did for him at the end of fast one
Dominic gives his brother his car keys
allowing him to escape at the family
Barbecue back in Los Angeles the teen
prepares to say grace but just before
Little Brian kicks off his first prayer
Brian O'Connor's car pulls up in the
driveway just in time for dinner I'm
curious to see how fast X handles Paul
Walker's character previously his
real-life Brothers acted as his
stand-ins and the VFX team used deep
fake Tech to reconstruct his features
with the support of Walker's family I
wonder if they'd ever do something
similar with AI in the days of future
fast the mid-credits scene shows Han
arriving at Shaw's Place seemingly to
confront him and be like I'm still
alive based on the trailer it looks like
we're gonna pick up with these to right
where this conversation leaves on we've
got a lot of loose ends from the
previous fast films that I'm dying to
see come into play in fast X but hit me
up in the comments and let me know what
details you think might come back to
haunt the Toretto family tree follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
foreign
[Music]